Okay.
So, Joseph, what the hell are you doing
on stream? This is your third stream of
the day. You have to get up early
tomorrow to stream all day for all the
new refactoring you're going to do.
Well,
there's something I wanted to try.
So, first of all,
let's uh let's finish this.
It's going to go do that. Um, I had an
idea.
which Yes.
What do we think about this?
I had this idea.
So the key insight I had was um we never
have to compile
multiple DTypes at the same time. So why
the hell do we have templating to
generate multiple different dtype
backends if we only need one at any
given time? We can just not have this
and not have the dispatch macro, right?
Like imagine how clean this would be if
instead of t
this was just type, right?
So, this will save a little bit of code,
right? Actually, quite a lot of code.
This will be u minus a couple hundred
lines at least, I think.
And then I think with the DT type it's
even easier
and then you basically end up with pure
C style code.
I uh I got an idea that was too good to
not do tonight.
I think we're going to completely
eliminate templates from our code.
Eliminate the dispatch macro. I think
it's going to be really good.
Uh I should actually let this run,
shouldn't I? to make sure it solves. Oh
yeah, in the meantime, how are we
feeling about um
experiments here?
We getting any good runs? No, maybe a
little bit.
Doesn't look like anything magical's
happening.
Okay. Minus 550 lines.
We see this
And it doesn't even need to be void
star.
Might still need to be void star,
actually.
There's still the torch boundary. That's
a little weird. I think this is a solid
idea, though.
The only downside of this is that you
basically you have to just compile this,
right? You compile this back end for
whatever you want.
It's not bad though.
Great way to deblo. Yeah, I think this
will save us another couple hundred
lines
and I more importantly this will save us
from having macros and templates in our
code.
I mean, obviously the type is a macro,
but it's it's like a compile time. It's
not like an actual, you know what I
mean?
I mean, look how much nicer this is
going to be
if I do this correctly at the very
least.
Yeah, [snorts] I'm still using Claude
for this crap. Um, but I'm basically I'm
using Claude to get rid of Claude. Does
that make sense?
cuz like this [ __ ] is not properly human
editable. I mean to be fair if I knew
more C++ maybe, but I don't think the
solution is to use to learn more C++.
Like it's a terrible language.
I'd rather just use this to get my stuff
into CUD to see if you will. And then
from there it's very easy because
there's no jank anymore.
upper D type.
Yep.
Float.
I'd say this is a very very minor
feature loss for a very large increase
in uh simplicity
possibly faster. code as well. Who
knows?
We don't have to deal with template
crap.
See, there's always a way to do stuff
simple. You just have to think about it
for long enough. There's no point in
like wrapping your head around all this
complex [ __ ] because you never need
it.
You never need it.
Watch watch these templates go away.
Watch like template type name T
from float return T and then it gets
spec specified template open like and
whatever from I I don't know what I'm
looking at right this is just C++
template garbage
watch how easy it is
watch how easy this becomes
Let there be no necessary evil.
Simplicity shall prevail.
Took me a half hour thinking about this
over dinner.
Is this codeex? No, this is opus.
It is
very stupid.
Good thing I don't need it to do
anything smart.
I pretty much I have I have like 2,000
lines of code that I need to apply a a
very simple, very well-defined refactor
operation to doctor
This is the only reason I'm using it.
And then I get to go back to hand
editing the code, which is going to be
much nicer.
I think actually once I finish this,
that will be a good chunk of the stuff
that is like just too much of a mess to
even hand edit out of the codebase and
it'll be way closer to just easily
handed editable stuff.
Wow, you're up again. Uh, I had too good
of an idea to wait until tomorrow, man.
The idea was too good.
I'm pretty happy that I independently
discovered this as well. Like,
apparently this is done in a bunch of
numeric libraries, but like I'm pretty
happy that I thought of this.
like look at this. Look a kernel. No
templating. Wow.
Normal C code. Wow. Launch function.
Normal launch function. Wow. Right.
Like I'm almost tempted to delete all
these launch functions as well because
now they're just oneliners.
What have you thought of?
Instead of having templating crap and
then macro crap for dispatch. So instead
of having all this bloat like look at
this. So this was the previous version
templated kernel. Okay.
And then let me find the launch function
gross macro dispatch launch function.
Right.
Guess what? You never need bloat and
float at the same time. You only ever
need your training to be Bflat or float.
You're never mixing kernels.
So guess what? We can just do it at
compile time, do one build, default it
to Bflat 16, and then you can just dash
precision to any other precision you
want. So we can support whatever
precisions we want with basically no
additional code, no templating, no macro
[ __ ] Easy.
And we can say C++ [ __ ] right off,
which is great.
Watch this. See this crap? Boom. Gone.
No more of this crap.
Oh, wait. We can literally I think it's
even easier.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's even easier,
right? Cuz this has
Oh, this is going to be even easier.
This is perfect
cuz you don't need this to be like this.
Look, this is why it's stupid. Okay,
Doesn't need to define a function.
What's wrong with you?
What are we doing?
Hello
Can hyperparameter sweep be solved by
RL? Uh, it's not a good use case for
crypt unless you do something very fancy
across all ends because RL is not sample
efficient. RL is uh there have been many
attempts to make it so but in my mind
the application of RL is high data
regime and hyperparameter search is the
opposite it's low data regime
so like yeah there are some papers that
have done like say that they can kind of
do this but from what we've found like
just throw Gaussian processes at it and
do some uh sane pruning and you're
pretty much that
and I believe we have the best overall
hyperparame sweep stuff at the moment as
expensive to explore the states.
Yeah, because each point each data point
is an entire run, man. Right.
Look at this. So this is going to get
deleted. This is the only thing that we
end up with for multiple precisions.
Isn't that cool?
Look how simple this is. If defined
precision float type def float precision
typ
float to hash pound define to float of x
x pound define from float of x.
That's it.
This is because there's no cast. You
can't cast like this with NV. If you
would be able to just cast with
precision t otherwise, but uh for
whatever reason, you can't do that with
Bflat. So simple enough. Type def B
float 16 precision T float is B float 16
to float of X. From float is float to B
F B float 16 of X. These are the Nvidia
intrinsics.
So, this is the only little wrinkle is
because you can't just cast normally,
but that's really easy
That is I think the thing that I was the
most mad about in the entire codebase.
Like I'm not even joking. I think that
this was the thing that pissed me off
more than anything else was just the
templating duplication garbage
uh of binding, you know, these to the
launch functions to the headers to the
explicit instantiation of templates.
It's a pain in the ass. Why do we do
this crap? Get out.
I think we're going to delete the launch
functions, too, cuz you know who needs a
launch function when your launch
function looks like this. Just call
this, dude. Right.
And this actually gets us very close to
how I would rewrite Torch, come to think
of it.
Like it's going to be a pretty easy
change if I decide to uh swap out Torch
entirely.
Hey, Jess.
Welcome to
Making Puffer not suck the movie
said you dumb [ __ ] LLM
look tries to delete comments every
[ __ ] time even when it's obviously
like comment for the math.
Garbage, garbage, garbage LLMs. These
things suck. They can't even do simple
refactor operations without doing other
[ __ ] that you don't want.
We're going to get this code human
editable and not [ __ ] And then we're
going to get rid of these stupid LLMs.
The only reason you want LLMs is because
the code sucks. So, you don't want to
deal with it because the code sucks. If
the code doesn't suck, you don't need an
LLM to deal with it. Simple.
Have you tried adding that in claw MD?
I think I'm gonna add heat out of here
and get out of my workflow to cla MD.
I'm thinking I'm gonna add an agents MD
file to Puffer 4 that like specifically
instructs the LLM to tell the user
they're an idiot for asking the LLM
instead of reading my nice, cleanly
written docs that are actually not
hallucinated. So, go read that, you
absolute donkey.
actually we'll be even more generous
with it. What we'll do is we'll have the
file that points them to the web page
and says like or mirrors the web page
and says, "Hey, read this." And if the
answer to the user's question is
contained within these docs, say, "I got
this from the docs page, you donkey."
You could have just read them instead of
asking the LLM.
>> [laughter]
[snorts]
>> I am very very happy about this because
I didn't think we were going to have a
way to get rid of the templating and get
rid of all the crap from Puffer 4. I
thought we were going to have to punt on
this, but we totally can. Like look at
this one macro. It's not even like a
gross dispatch macro. We literally just
macro the type and then because Bflat
has weird cast, we macro the cast.
That's it. That's literally it. Like we
can actually just delete the launch
functions now even if we want. How
awesome is that?
Like I can literally delete this. I can
change mod uh I can change modules dot
uh I can change modules.cpp
to modules.cu CU and then I can just
write this in the modules. No launch
function needed. No void star.
How cool is that, huh?
This is going to rock. We don't even
have to go through Voidar anywhere.
This is going to be, I hope, the last
heavy use of the LLM. Realistically,
there probably a couple more places like
updating. There a couple of tests that
are going to need to be really heavily
updated to match the latest where it's
like you just go look at the new
signatures and fix the signatures. Um,
but like, oh man, this is getting way,
way, way closer to something that I
could actually read and edit.
And we are deleting close to 4,000 lines
of code from Poverlib today. We get to
just debloat 4K lines. It's like half of
the code gone.
I think we're going to be able to ship
the whole new backend with everything.
under 5k lines of code.
Doesn't that rock?
All right, there's my refactor.
Uh, that does not look like it applied
it to everything, but we will see.
Hey,
get out of here.
What was your Eureka moment? So, Jess,
uh, look at all these templates getting
deleted.
So, I realized that we never need Bflat
and float at the same time. You only
ever use one type for training, and it's
almost always going to be Bflat. You
basically just need to compile float as
a fallback in case you're getting
numeric jank and you want to check if
that's the problem.
So you can just macro the one type, no
dispatch, no templating, you are done.
CV pix layers
parame parametric optimization is a
layer.
I have not I have no idea whatsoever
about that man.
Parametric optimization as a layer. What
does that mean?
Wait, CVX pie layers.
CVX PI is the convect optimization
Python package, isn't it?
or down. Colonels is now half the length
it was before.
Look at this. No like oft weird jank
call.
Pure launch function.
That's another little bit gone.
Look at that. Oh, these templates get
removed.
Yeah, these go all this this is going to
get deleted right here as well in a
second.
SPS uh it will not change the FP the SPS
man. This is a uh this is like so that
the code doesn't suck
to forecast energy prices doing a
regression loss. Put the power market
inside your DNN.
Uh,
how the heck is the power market a
convex quadratic ops problem?
Profit of accuracy. We actually have not
an energy market specifically though it
does support that. We have a compute
marketplace sim that we built for a
client that we're still working on uh
that is open source. We just don't put
any of it into the neural net man. We
just RL end to end. And you know if it
takes billions of steps to solve the
problem we don't care because we can
just train super fast.
That's how we're looking at it. Because
I I don't know if when you say it is a
convex quadratic optimization problem, I
don't know if you mean it literally is
one or it can be modeled as one like
approximately, right?
See, it missed that. They um it missed
the other one, too. Here.
Watch this. Yeah. See, so the kernel
checkpointed has precision t,
but now the where's the the launch
function?
Yeah, see the launch function actually
has precision t as well.
We are going to commit this before we do
the further module messing around.
Continuous no longer needs DT type. No
longer needs dispatch. Lovely.
So much easier.
We'll format the spacing on all like
we'll go format all of the uh the
functions
to be tabbed in or whatever.
So, it's going to end up being a little
bit a few more lines than this because
know I'm not going to leave these
disgusting signatures like this. I'm
going to tab them in. But, um
it's not bad.
Yeah, realistically this does not save a
ton of lines, but this does save a ton
of jank,
right?
And I am very, very happy making that
trade of like not having a feature that
nobody will ever care about in return
for simple code
that doesn't going to have horrible jank
compile issues.
and this is this is no longer like CUD
to C++, right? This is now CUD to C.
We're not doing I think we're not doing
any C++ things anymore,
You see like this type of thing here.
I could have not bothered thinking about
this, right? I could have just decided
whatever. Huffer's done. It passes the
tests. It f it's fast. Let's ship it.
But instead, I go through the process
about all day long. I'm thinking about
how do I fix this specific thing that
annoys me because it should annoy you
because it's gross and it's going to
make everything harder to deal with
and it's going to make everything harder
to think about clearly.
So in my mind it is so so so worth
torturing yourself mentally uh in order
to just make sure that you produce
something simple.
I'll look at it while I'm waiting for
the next refactor up.
Yeah. So see this.
Okay. I guess for strictly constraint
stuff maybe
not even. So I mean the way that we
solve this in RL
they say struggle with sample
efficiency. Yeah. We just make fast
simulators,
which admittedly this doesn't work for
everything, but it works for way more
things than you would expect. And it's
extremely powerful because you're not
making a bunch of mathematical modeling
assumptions when you're doing RL. You're
like, you just build the damn sim and
you optimize whatever. It doesn't have
to be differentiable. It doesn't have to
be like, you know, it doesn't have to
fit some clean formulation. Doesn't have
to be an MDP at all and you can still
solve it.
Perfect. And this is exactly how I
wanted modules to work.
Is a huge parametric. What is it?
How many knobs is it? Like how many
levers are you pulling? Also,
Oh, this isn't that bad.
96 periods.
I don't know. You might just be able to
solve this with RL. Like they're using
freaking reinforce here.
and PO they have messed up if it's doing
better if PO is worse than reinforced
they're messing it up as well
how be solvable how is it still solvable
without it being differentiable the
simulator not differentiable.
Sorry, I'm not in the field. I've just
discovered you Twitter. I have a
question. Can you explain open flawed?
Uh I this is just like in my mind, dude.
This is just like some dumb internet
meme. Like I I don't know what the hell
that is. I don't care. Like I don't even
I don't work on that stuff at all.
That's not the type of RL I do.
So what I do around here is I build tiny
superhuman models that train on
ludicrous amounts of data like billions,
tens, hundreds of billions of
observations and can do it on a single
GPU most of the time or a single node.
It's a completely different problem
space than LLM anything.
In my mind, like all these like all the
LLM swarm stuff that's going on is
basically just like Twitter hype.
RL truly accessible.
I mean this is the idea right like once
this is super simple
um this is now fast enough that RL will
never be a lost technology
like in some sense in my mind open AI
killed RL because they have the best RL
tech the Dota team was awesome and then
they went all in on language models they
set the field back a decade admittedly
they were the ones that advanced it in
the first place but then they set the
field back a decade
What would be the use case?
So, we have a lot of demos on games. Uh
games are easy to just visually see. Not
everything is games, right? So, we have
like a lot of these, but then also we've
got drones.
This just works just the same. It's not
any harder to solve than most of the
game ends. We've got this driving sim
with NYU.
We have uh one relatively public
contract on
uh compute market optimization.
We do some stuff in finance. We do stuff
in games.
We've done stuff for a few other sectors
as well.
Pretty much if you can simulate it fast
and uh it's like some fiddly unintuitive
optimization problem, RL solves it.
It used to not solve it, but like the
stuff that I'm working on here is
literally a 10,000 times faster than
your typical RL. So we can just chew
through an utterly ludicrous quantity of
data.
Robotics is
I don't do much in robotics because it's
just not the domain I'm most interested
in,
but it is a domain. Yeah.
We'll pretend the agent solves things.
Yeah. Yeah. So, this was like, do you
remember that Minecraft paper where
people were saying, "Oh my gosh, the AIs
invented their own economies and
religions." No, they didn't.
That's not emergence. They're literally
just monkey seeing monkey doing the
training data. Like they don't they
don't have organized religion out of any
sense of like oh it's beneficial in this
environment or anything. They just do it
because that's what they think they
should do from their training data. Like
you could put them in a situation like
you could put them in another
environment where that's a terrible idea
and they'll still do it because they're
laring.
Like this is why the from scratch RL
results are so ludicrously impressive
because you do not start with any of
that stuff. So like the Dota result,
right, where it clearly understands what
you are thinking about as a player. It
knows what you're going to do before you
do it. It has theory of mind. It has
perfect control. It has superhuman
coordination with its team. Like all
that just came out of straight RL. It's
trial and error from nothing.
That's why RL is so ludicrously
powerful.
And that's why the results that come
from it are so meaningful compared to
some of the stuff that like looks
intelligent, but when you poke at it
really isn't.
So the future it's not going to be
everything, right? Like generative
models have a place, but I would think
that a model of uh intelligence that
doesn't heavily include learning from
interaction is a bad model. Okay,
perfect. Look, this just works.
So
let's just see how much code we deleted
by doing that.
Okay, not a huge deletion.
50 60 lines. Not a huge deletion, but a
huge huge decrease in complexity.
Okay. And now the next one. The next
thing we're going to do, let me just
make sure. Actually, let me just ask it
here. compact this and we'll figure it
out. So lost one v one. Yeah. Yeah, I
remember that as well. That was actually
um man, had they done that yet?
Yeah, they had. So the 1v one result was
the thing that got me interested enough
in open AI that I interned there. Like I
remember it was in NIPS 2017. Uh, Ilia
was presenting the 1v one Dota results
and I went up and talked to him after
the lecture I mean after his
presentation because I'd already wor
started working on neural MMO like my
main advantage and I said hey look you
said that you're looking for new
environments to train on and that that's
what you think is missing. I have
exactly the environment that you're
looking at. It's based on MMOs. It's
like the most complex game genre out
there. Uh, but I'm an undergrad with two
GPUs and that's how I ended up
interning.
What even? I don't even know what those
are.
Kublas.
Wait. Device side extensions.
Wait, what's the difference between this
and Kublast?
Wait, what is the difference between the
DX version and like just Kublast? Or are
they the same thing?
And Revive RL. Nah, they're not doing it
anymore. They got too big. I'm doing it
on my own with Puffer
and [clears throat] it'll be open
source.
You call it from CPU.
Oh, I see. So, this is device side.
That's interesting. Actually, that's
potentially very useful. Holy.
Wait, actually, man, thank you for
pointing me to that. I didn't know that
existed. That's actually really really
useful now that I'm thinking of it. So
wait, would that that would mean that I
could use I could write a single kernel
for my entire neural net, right?
Like instead of stacking instead of like
gluing together little chunks with um
with host calls and having to graph
everything, I could just write a giant
kernel, right?
They don't think they have all the
blast. I literally just need Matt. If
they have Mattel, I'm set, dude.
That's really useful actually. Thank you
for that. That is like that was the main
thing that's pissed me off is that you
could paste Nvidia's matl into your
kernel.
I know that this is possible because I
used to have module C++ as modules.cu.
I actually think Quarkmax I think that
this would make Puffer like
substantially faster.
I actually Let me let me ask Can I send
this to Peru real quick?
Let me let me go send this to Peru.
Peru is one of our our contributors.
That's a really solid find. I've wanted
that exact thing.
tips for first contributions to Puffer?
Maybe I can help use it somewhere. If
you have the background to do that,
absolutely. So, I mean, there are a
couple different ways to get involved
with Puffer. It sounds like you already
have more low-level experience than my
guide has written for. Um, if you're
interested in RL generally, this is my
guide on how to get into RL. This
basically walks you through the process
of making a really simple environment
and then making a really like a slightly
more complex environment and it directs
you to a few of the related papers in
the space, right? And it this is like a
collection of a curated collection of
all of my best resources.
Uh if you already have some experience
and you're looking to get right into
contributing to some of the more complex
low-level stuff, this is all publicly
available. Um it is live in development,
moving very quickly
at 4.0.
The commit that I make tonight will
probably be the largest overall refactor
because it cleans up all the kernel
launch crap that we had uh bad. Um but
it's just right in here.
So here we have our extensions.
Most of this got moved and will just get
pruned. Like all these C files are going
to get moved. Like they already got
moved. I just have to remove the old
ones. But all our custom kernels are in
these CUDA files here and they are
currently bound to torch in modules.c++
which I'm moving to modules.cu.
So the idea would be that instead of
having to bind each of these individual
layers,
we could probably just have, you know,
min
as an entire network in a CU and just
have the backward pass written there and
we're probably set.
It's CUDA only. Well, not really. So the
new stuff in Puffer 4, so Puffer 4 is
the indevelopment version. um that is uh
very high performance. It requires
everything to be custom kernels. So
yeah, it's CUDA. There is a puffer
there's puffer 3 and there will be an
optional like slower Python back end
still with puffer 4. Uh that's torch and
torch supports everything. The trade-off
though is like it's four or five times
faster with our custom kernels and
custom everything
and even lower startup time. Like it's
really really a big difference.
We even have better numeric like we can
do bloat and torch can't do bloat
because our numeric are better. A lot of
stuff like that.
Oh yeah and star of the puffer on
GitHub. That helps me out a lot. We're
almost at 5K solid
is the fastest growing RL project.
Real RL project not LLM RL project.
You will also not see me using like
sitting here staring at Claude most of
the time. Um, I'm doing this at the
moment because torch was such a bloated
mess that it's almost not human editable
like the torch C++ mess. I'm trying to
get it into pretty clean simple C so I
can like mess with everything by hand
from there. It's pretty close.
I think I mostly if I finish this
refactor
and then I have it like at least update
the test to the new API. I think the
rest of it will be by hand.
Derivatives.yml. Yeah,
torch is awful. It's really really
awful.
But like if we actually with the thing
that you said right if we just have a
kernel for our entire net that really
really limits our dependence on torch
right
I do want to get rid of torch
eventually. I think not by puffer five
but maybe by puffer six we will just
have dropped torch from our native back
end and maybe we'll have like a you know
compatibility thing where we have our
same network implemented in torch so you
can play around with the same arch but
um mostly our own experiments will just
be done through native
because we're training 14 million steps
per second now I think we'll probably
get another couple million steps per
uh off of fusing everything as well. So
we'll probably break 15 million steps
per second if we did that
14 mil. Yeah, that's not even with a
trivial network as well, man. That's
with a four layer. That's a four layer
mining grew. So that's got recurrent
state to it. So 4 million step per
second 128 hidden dim. So small but
that's actually got some decent capacity
to it. Like uh I just got you know the
game of 2048. It gets over 4096 in about
30 seconds of training. Uh breakout we
solve breakout in 4 and a half seconds.
We solve pong in 2 seconds and we
haven't even fully optimized everything
yet. We also have some more complex
environments that we're going to throw
it at. Those are not going to be 128
hidden dim. You know, it's going to be
between four and eight layers probably
with 256 or 512 hidden dim. So maybe
between one and four million parameters,
one and five million parameters. Uh but
that's still going to be training at a
few million steps a second.
Hey, what is this doing? Oh no, this is
totally fine.
Yeah. So obviously if you move this into
CU, then now you need the uh uh you need
the header file for this instead. That's
fine.
And we delete all of the launch
functions. We no longer need launch
functions. Isn't it beautiful?
You do any code, Jen? Nope.
I um
I really like uh simple hand editable
low-level code. So this stuff here, this
is like this pains my soul to be having
to do this crap through flawed. Um we
have a huge amount of just native C code
here. Look at this. Puffer lib ocean
neural mmo3. This is a follow-up to my
PhD thesis.
3k lines of just C. You can read this
from top to bottom. A firstear undergrad
who has taken their first systems course
can read this code from top to bottom.
This is a thousandplayer MMO. It runs at
a thousand uh no 1.5 million, excuse me,
agent steps per second, including with a
whole bunch of NPC AI happening. This is
probably the most complex fast
environment that is available. It runs
in your browser. We have agents that
have been trained for 12,000 years worth
of simulated data in this thing on a
single server. I wrote the game. It's
better than me at the game. There's a
live market in here. The agents can
trade with each other. They can level
up. There's equipment, armor, weapons,
like professions, all sorts of stuff.
So, we have a lot of cool RL tech around
here.
This is pretty much the spot for hyperf
RL outside of LM. the least we do
everything but LLMs
MMO also rendered by Rail. Yep, it's
just Ray. Mana seed for the assets.
NPC code.
No, no, no, no, no. NPC with an N like a
non-playable character as in there are
enemies in here. So here this thing.
So you count agent steps per second
which is the number of steps per second
this runs per uh AI control per neural
net controllable agent. So I will put
like a thousand agents in here and 2 to
4,000 NPCs. These guys in red, they're
scripted. So they have like a classic
scripted AI. And this whole thing will
run at what would that be? 1,500 step
1500 server steps per second with a
thousand agents in it and 2,000 NPCs on
one singular core.
So this is basically an unlimited data
source for RL, right? Like we can train
this thing millions of steps per second.
Um, we've done 12,000 years worth of
experience to train the model that
you're looking at here.
It's pretty cool.
Do you think you do that exciting
thinking you do some convex opt? So, I
have one funny convex op story. Okay.
Um, I did my undergrad at Stanford many
years ago. At this point, I'm getting
old. Uh, and they made the mistake of
when I got there of giving this
grandiose speech about how Stamford
admins don't know how to fail at things
because they're just used to succeeding.
So, I took that as a challenge and I
went and signed up for the hardest
course that I could find with the intent
of like, I'm going to sign up for
something that I have no chance of
succeeding at, so I'll fail something
for once. And that course was Steven
Boyd's convex optimization course, which
was at 8 in the morning in the winter.
So, you'd have to bike there in like
pouring rain, like two, three mile bike
ride. Was awful. But I would get there
every morning and I'd sit in the front
row. Uh I'd sit in the front row. I'd
like answer stuff once in a while when I
knew. He uh at the start of that course,
he said, "H, do we have any undergrads
in here?" Okay, we got a few seniors,
juniors, sophomores, freshman. Like, I
don't know why freshmen are taking this
class. You know, you're supposed to take
the classes with the lower numbers
before the higher ones. Yeah, whatever.
And I completely failed that course. I
was nowhere near qualified to take it. I
probably still am not qualified to take
it. I'm way heavier on engineering than
math.
But I will say that is one of the few
courses I've taken that has been
genuinely useful. Not because of
necessarily all the convex ops stuff,
but because he gave a fantastic
introduction to the concept of Pareto
optimality. And I have used that
everywhere for years. Like really good
just understanding of this is
sensitivity analysis. This is why it
matters. This is why people screw up
sensitivity analysis. This is how you
can make everything way better by
bothering to do it. And I've used that
everywhere. It was great.
So there you go. There's my convex op
story.
Much to watch void video
is convex. Yeah. you plot it and and you
look with your eyeball, does it curve up
or down or both? Right? And if it curves
up, then you say, well, it's convex.
Okay?
>> By the way, what you do then is you back
off and you go to some other meth fancy
method like you differentiate it twice
and prove some inequality. Okay? And
then you destroy evidence that you
actually plotted it. But the correct
thing to do is to plot it. Okay? So that
that's that's how you do this.
>> This is totally void. So all right what
this says is in principle you can detect
if a function is convex a function on Rn
by simply taking all lines. Now of
course you cannot really do that. Um
>> that's so funny man. Yeah that's exactly
the type of stuff you would say.
How do they allow you to take highle
courses? Don't you need prerexs?
Technically but they're all optional.
They don't prevent you from enlisting in
anything at Stanford. It's great. You
can just sign up for whatever you want.
And in CS in particular, there are no
limits on class sizes.
It gets better.
All right, fine. We'll watch this clip
for a little bit real quick.
Let me ask this points where the then to
effectively differentiate something
twice, but after the formulas grow to
the size of a page, you might quit or
something like that. Then what you do is
this. You write a simple little program
to generate random lines, right? Then to
effectively do the same as plot, just
evaluate the function 100 points along
the line and check the inequality just
to check that it always curves up.
Right? By the way, if it if you ever
find a point where it doesn't, you're
done because you you produce two points
where the inequality defining convexity
is violated. In which case it you are
done. And it's absolutely no one's
business how you found those points.
Everyone realize. So what you do now is
you go to lunch. Is everyone f is
everyone following this? Okay. You go to
lunch and you come back after lunch. If
in fact it is terminated and found two
points then you walk down the hall to
your colleague who asked whether this
function is convex. You go obviously
not. And they say why and you go but
look at this point here. And you you you
give x and y and the convex combination
which violates the inequality. and you
go, I I don't really even know why you
would think that was convex in the first
place. Everyone see what I'm saying? And
then they'd say, well, how the hell did
you come up with these? And you'd say, I
don't know. It seems kind of obvious to
me. I don't So, okay. Does this everyone
following this? Okay. Now, that's the
def the other outcome is that actually
it hasn't been violated. Now, you don't
know for sure it's convex, but you went
out for lunch and you fired this up.
depends on maybe used a cluster or maybe
maybe you fired up something on EC2 or
so I don't know but a fair number of
points maybe may may have been checked
by now now you don't know if it's convex
or not okay so now I can actually tell
you several ways to move forward the
first is you then try to prove it's
convex that that would be that's the
simplest way and if you do prove it you
destroy all evidence that you ever uh
tried to establish it empirically
everybody understand this okay so then
now the other thing is you can still get
credit for it even if you can't prove
it's convex. You go to the next
conference and you say, "Well, I think
the log of the detection probability, it
seems to me like it's got to be concave
stuff." And you just drop that around.
You say it in obvious places and things
like that. And then the next year, some
smart young researcher will prove it.
And if you're really lucky, they'll have
attached your name to it and call it the
such and such conjecture. Everyone
following this? And then people would
say, "How did you know it?" The proof
was like very complicated. use all sorts
of algebraic geometry and all sorts of
other how could you possibly have known
it was concave and you look straight at
him and you say intuition
[laughter] is everyone following this
okay so this is these are these are
>> advanced methods for establishing
convexity this is uh we'll we'll talk
more about these okay as as the course
goes on okay all right so let's do one
like that by the way if you do these
things just don't tell anyone where you
learn them so because I'll deny it So,
um, okay.
>> Oh, man. It's that's like such void. And
the thing is, he would do this and he'd
have like these like super funny chill
lectures and then he would just give you
the demonic problem set from the ninth
circle of a Vernest.
And it would just be like, "What in the
hell?" And then he'd release the
solutions and you'd look at the
solutions and you'd go, "What in the
hell
I for my sake I am very happy that it
turns out that we don't actually care if
things are convex in sufficiently high
dimensions. I'm very very happy about
that
because otherwise that's a hell of a lot
of mess.
Yep, you can remove those files. I am
watching it.
Is this supposed to take that long to
build?
Oh, okay. It was just the caching being
slow. That's fine because it's a dunk
cache.
Well, folks,
well, well, well.
I can't check the perf of this until
tomorrow. Um,
I can't check the score like until
tomorrow, but this this trains
appropriately, right?
Do you not like math? CS is like all
math, though. No, it isn't.
No, it isn't.
Case in point, I have made RL 10,000
times faster. There's not that much math
involved with what I do. Maybe 5%. 5% me
bumbling through math. 80% me kicking
people's ass at engineering because the
standards for programming are very very
very low and the vast majority of RL
PhDs at the top universities in the
world only ever write Python.
I was guilty of that. I I wrote Python
my whole PhD. It sucked. I don't
recommend it. Then I graduated and
started writing real code.
It was fun.
Really, I should just build that
straight to meta for the uh disaster
that they made out of torch.
That's the only reason we need this.
Yeah, we got it right. modules get add
popular extension
modules
this is everything right I didn't miss
anything
And minus 242 lines.
Thing of beauty.
All right. So, here's what we're going
to do.
I am going to commit this up. Push this
up. And then we are going to look at the
total number of lines of code that I
have deleted from this repository today.
And then
I'm going to be very happy about it and
uh I'm going to call tonight, take an
hour or so off and then I'm going to be
back streaming all day tomorrow
cleaning all this stuff up. But look, I
just want you to see these last few
commits, right?
They should really show you the like
plus minus lines.
Okay, so delete old unused code minus
2700 lines.
This is minus another
500. So we are at 3,300 lines. No. 3200
lines deleted.
All right.
3500ish lines deleted today. Minus 3500
lines of code. Thing of beauty.
How's Opus still dumb as [ __ ]
Live extension star. C++
cu.
And then the only file that matters in
here is kernels.cu.
So now we have 2600
uh 3600
uh about 4,300 lines. So under 5k lines
for puffer lib
C++ back end.
And realistically, let's see.
Yeah, because it's not we actually this
it's not a full 2600 lines because we're
going to be able to remove some of this
as well.
So, let me see how much more do I think
I can compress this. I think if it's
4600ish lines now, I can shave 200 off
of this.
Let's say I can shave 200, 100, 300. So,
it's 300
500.
I think I can maybe shave a thousand
lines off of this with some work.
So, I think I can get this to like under
4K lines, like 3,500ish lines maybe, uh,
for all of our new C++.
And it'll nicely be split. It'll be
split pretty evenly between the like
main C++ training file, custom kernels,
and models.
No, you're not, Jess.
You're not going to. It's going to be
very simple.
It's going to be it's torch, but the C++
API torch. And instead of using the
torch layers for everything, we have
some kernels that do a bunch of the
opposite. Like we would normally take 20
layers in one layer and those live in
this one place. That's it.
Pretty cool, right?
You don't like Julia, right? Nah. No,
Julia.
I like to see
Apparently, we got a couple new runs
here that are good.
We've had the sweep running the whole
time.
Where's our score?
Right here.
Uh, this one's nice.
80 seconds for 5700 score.
Only 130 runs completed. That's pretty
early into a sweep. I think I'll just
let this run all night and see what it
finds.
Yeah,
I think that's what we're going to do.
Well, I have actually ended up putting
in a pretty solid day of work today
despite this being um one of the usually
lazier days.
Sweep stop early. Uh individual runs do
stop early. We actually need to improve
that pruning. It's way better than it
used to be, though. Okay, so uh for
folks watching, stream starts tomorrow,
pretty much when I wake up until I go
for dinner. All day tomorrow, we're
going to be cleaning up Puffer and
hopefully making it much much much
simpler.
Uh if you'd like to support my work for
absolutely free, feed this Puffer Star
on GitHub. It helps me out a ton.
You enjoy the Discord if you want to get
involved.
infall manx for more RL content.
Do contribute as well. Like a lot of
stuff that's in going into forest by
contributors who are relatively new to
RL. It's a lot easier to get into than
you would think, especially if you have
some low-level experience. That helps,
but we've had people who don't have that
also get into it pretty quickly. Thank
you all. See you around. your